actuellement je lâche le bouton rond et
je décède yacht le monde sait squeeze on
se retrouve sur la mise à jour 2 go
simulator ce n'est pas le manque de
tomber sur la présentation d'enel parce
qu'il nous reste plein de trucs à faire
et je vole t'avais les gens sont
vraiment de plus en plus chez nous dans
cette ville ya un gros problème une
sorte de virus en fait je savais pas
mais cette chèvre un poids
extraordinaire
c'est un peu comme spider man elle tisse
des langues c'est un peu alors vous avez
été hyper nombreux à me demander d'aller
sur l'île qu'on avait vu la vidéo
précédente si c'est vrai qu'au final je
ne suis pas allé 1 c'est parti
oh [ __ ] hommes et des martyrs est quoi
je savais où je suis accroché à temps
mais voilà c'est moi y'a pas de soucis
non plus il ya un souci relève toi
[ __ ] mais elle est morte elle est
décédée elle est mouillée
ces bannières désole un génie qu'est ton
plan drague au québec elle est désolée
je détiens mais [ __ ] c'est bon on est
accroché on n'est pas accroché allez
allez on est bien on est bien il ya le
truc qui nous retient on est bien oui
oui non oui c'est compliqué c'est un peu
tendu comme situation on y va on va sur
l'it les gens vous avez été à peu près
un million a demandé d'y aller je crois
qu'ils oublient aussi bonne que nous le
producteur et on est arrivé ok c'est
it's a trap c'est un piège
comment ça c'est un peu le coin ils se
déplacent dans l'eau comme une chienne
chez pathé sens c'est un peu mieux
déplacer quand même j'en aie aie à notre
pote c'est quoi ça un sac plastique pour
mieux se suicider voilà on y est et donc
c'est ça la fameuse île que vous voyez
tout ce que j'avais mais vous m'avez
troll un [ __ ] ya absolument rien
bateau khaled mois attention je me fâche
ok je me fâche voilà si avec cette
chèvre la face on peut dire que c'est
une chèvre je fais du vélo comment ça se
passait là il ya un vélo juste là haut
du skate mais bon y'a rien de plus
ridicule que ça quoi
est-ce que je suis pas moi-même un
skateboard quand je fais ça si je vais
100 fois plus vite tu veux chez tiennent
la main c'est ça non là moi je m'ai fait
de pingouins biatch on t'a jamais dit
que c'était dangereux
tu es dans des ruelles sombres sous
peine de atom et j'ai même pas eu le
temps de t'agresser la poubelle
t'agresse coiffa victimes ou à victimes
maintenant les chais là je m'en vais
lâche mois complet c'est dans un hôtel
boutique par ici à léon footing
d'ensemble au footing d'ensemble stop
calme toi jéjé transpercé tout ce qui
est est malin qui est en fait une épée
je ne sais pas monte dessus eux qu'est
le trx japonais à faire un petit clip
c'est tout voilà regarder au delà ça
suffit skateboard revient et si aulas
mais c'est dangereux de traverser comme
ça mon gars hop là haut vol une hache
on va braquer une maison on braque une
plantation c'est ça être un gangster
[ __ ] hockey suisse est un braquage oui
là c'est qu'il ya à manger le sol où est
l'argent on est une statue je cherche de
l'argent mon gars à temps mais attends
mais c'est pas bien où garer mais qui se
droguent carrément passé explique
pouvait parler un mur aussi [ __ ] non
watts
sugar rush cette somme fine sugar faire
aud'imat drogués [ __ ] beach bataille
haha ça va mieux je me sens qu'est ce
qu'ils font ces billets quoi [ __ ] mais
c'est un cerveau l'on sait des billets
on va être acceptée c'est sûr tu veux
rentrer dans cette boîte de nuit j'ai de
l'argent
pardon je peux entrer là j'ai des
billets je veux rentrer g2 l'argent tant
pis je vais entrer par la porte de côté
et merde
cette scène est carrément chaude
et même on prend goût à 6 mais ça suffit
d'aller talent qui pend nom des blagues
ratées
hachey mois au plus tard bonjour je veux
un chapeau le pur style oh [ __ ] pardon
tu as je veux juste voir ton stand d eux
ne font pas trop ma force peut dire que
je fais à peu près 50 cm de haut
attention regardez quoi ses petites
fesses de pas loin qui bouge de gauche à
droite comme ça sensuellement au le
camion est ce qui bien sûr mais je fais
le tour de france qu'est ce qui se passe
ou pas au cross je sais pas combien de
temps on va tenir mais voilà à skate
park mon gars qui tourne à prêter gisèle
mondiale ce site est un vol faux plat
non ok c'est bon c'est parti mon gars ok
ce qui se passe et ça sert à quoi
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire la blague du
s'était pas cette blague l'âge oui c'est
pas du tout pris le ballon
c'est l'heure pour moi de prendre mon
envol est parti d'un tintin est bas mais
non mais c'est pas ça que je me fais je
veux juste aller en face au paraguay
tatata ça marche nickel parfait bah
c'est vrai que je voulais faire voilà
voir un petit peu le dessous de la map
lui faire un petit peu coucou puisque je
pense que l'oubli beaucoup un camp jouer
à god simulator
est ce que je sais c'est pas la
meilleure cachette possible et
maintenant j'étais caché vous voulez pas
trouvé au revoir ce qu est le skateboard
un sport plein de sensations d'un
nouveau simulateur jeu tangue un peu
mais c'est le style attendez attendez
demi tour rentrons là dedans
taiana fumée dégueulasse watts ok le
succès le plus intense et une grille
ouais un trou noir là bas un couloir
c'est ça qu'on veut
watanabe m'adresse pas vous y allez je
joue bien je visite comme ça les écouler
ces tortues ninja les samoa
laissez-moi temps tunisien [ __ ] vous
vous êtes enflammé regard je vous ai
tous mis ko
non non ça marche pas comme ça eh bien
je vais bien je reviens avec une arme
très dangereuse
j'aurais bien presté à l'attack le crâne
le plus dangereux du monde qui a tapé
mon coin coin hein qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est pas comme ça qu'on s'assoit
sur une chaise je peux pas le kidnappeur
gardez le alors quand vous battez
montrez-moi excuse non mais déjà c'est
pas ça que je vois ça
attends mais c'est sa toute attaque
spéciale tibia contre crâne chauve non
dans sa marche pas je m'en vais gisèle
gizeh hockey gisèle est restée cachée
dans ce truc
gisèle sort de la [ __ ] gisèle c'est
toi de moi ta main gisèle c'est une chef
ça mais ce chan tim roth ont déconné
mais tant que je peux faire tomber
directeur si je veux aller comme ça mais
non attendez est-ce que ça le fait
tomber
ah non mais c'est nul tu me cache c'est
un chat ronronne hockey une pour
l'europe pas ok cette batterie rend la
traction 100% en plus folles comme ça le
truc va beaucoup plus vite comme si
j'avais la force pour tes gisèle quoi
gisèle cette fois ça va être deux fois
plus excitant que la dernière fois je ne
parle pas de la sorcière gisèle je pars
de l'attraction
allez on y va scheifele rôle d'agent ben
là j'ai un peu mal au bide la taxe
yonatan que nous premier rang c'est
parti je me suis accroché gisèle on y va
gisèle ça va aller te fois plus vite je
te pousse avait vraiment bien accroché
tant les mecs comme l'attraction elle a
fait non cette fois gisèle tu
t'accroches bien j'en ai marre de ratés
du tournoi traction par ta faute
c'est parti premièrement mais non mais
non
mais si cette [ __ ] alors là tu l'a
voulu je suis un pingouin fâché
désormais par ta faute
voilà car sous la nuque dans ce banc à
gisèle alors que j'accroche ma langue
non [ __ ] mais j'ai l'habitude fait que
de la merde tu fais que de la merde
gisèle [ __ ] mais regarde par ta faute
quoi tu avais juste je suis pas un wagon
[ __ ] gisèle terrain tu vois ce
barbecue et ben tu le beauf gisèle
moeurs voilà brûle ça a l'air de
tellement de faire mal ça chatouille
langues
bon j'ai débloqué la django tu en rien
c'est une chèvre
regardez même elle elle le dit à gueule
le jetpack de la malène alors jeune
bateau qui vous a tant fait chier vas-y
des marbres démarche t'empêche jetant
pêche
qu'est ce tu fais mon gars je crois
qu'il empêche absolument pas non il doit
le très tu fais quelque chose ce métier
et me prend aux otages
qu'est ce qui va se passer quelque chose
bonjour mais non en quoi pourquoi je
vous à dégager comme ça je t'aimais
freddy regarde je me frotte plus tôt
contre toi je fais le bon frais derrière
je te montent dessus freddy contre
tongres et j'en ai rien à [ __ ] freddy
on est si bien comme ça ah oui gratte
moi le dos à j'aime tellement ça mais
non 13 10
mais non mais voilà voilà voilà voilà à
cause de freddy je finis sdf entre deux
bâtiments c'est génial tu as monde est
pris au piège dans des drapeaux quoi des
sortes de pièges à balen moderne s'il te
plait je ne pourrais tu me passes et le
vélo oh oui c'est bien ça ce que tu fais
c'est bien non c'est moi bien là on
pourra jamais faire de vélo je vais
presque rage et surtout qu'à septembre
dans mes fesses [ __ ] je suis sur terre
et je suis au cra le plus diabolique de
la planète jeu s'est arrêté des voitures
compagnie camion mais des voitures
il suffit juste de les rattraper avant
la grèce les gens bible non là c'est les
poubelles je fais des blagues pas drôles
dépressif
bîmes je suis cramé j'ai des tongs parce
que excusé stylet j'ai de la peine pour
elle je ne fais pas le parking je passe
devant l'homme avec les sorties donner
de l'argent oui mettant des coups de
tatane à la vitre et cet homme n'était
en fait pas peur c'est gisèle mon
ex-femme où tu au courant et je suis cru
piège dans une voiture peut terminer ce
mois les sports où je te bouffe tout des
pneus voilà je fais comme les vrais
chèvres et j'ai fait un gros câlin
qu'alain plutôt fusionnelle je ne sais
pas faire de mélo un don quand je pars
en mission je pars pas en vélo je
m'assois sur la roue avant
voilà bah c'est mon petit style à moi
pour la samro unique qu'est ce qui fait
effet d'activité bizarre cet homme v
devait intervenir
john beyrle robert jour le maillot belge
voilà c'est fait et voilà j'ai bien
caché sous le banc je regardais plus
près si tu me permets et bah non c'est
une fois que mon gars tu parles d'un
repas d'automne de l'agencé dia fin de
cette deuxième vidéo sur la mise à jour
2 go de simulateurs si vous aimez les
baleines les crabes les spyder god tout
ça vous pouvez mais la vidéo ça fera foi
au plaisir et puis on se retrouve très
vite dans une nouvelle vidéo
je souhaite bonne chance à ceux qui
passent le bac la semaine prochaine vous
inquiétez pas tout va bien se passer et
ses autres pairs qui vous le dit
regarder danser son crâne
bon ben je vous le dis pas tant pis tu
as tout le monde 1920 dr